I don't know about you but I like
writing less code particularly
boilerplate code alongside API 24 we've
included support for a number of Java 8
language features with the help of the
Jack tool chain to use any of these new
features you'll need to enable the Jack
tool chain all it takes is just a few
lines of code in your build.gradle file
and you're all set now to cut that
boilerplate code firstly you'll be able
to use lambda expressions a simplified
way of expressing functional interfaces
interfaces with just a single method
this allows us to rewrite our on-click
listeners from all this down to
something a little easier to look at
you'll note that parameter types are
optional here we're using braces to
allow you to have multiple statements
just like a normal method but if you
only have a single expression you can
leave them out a sister feature - lambda
expressions method references allow you
to use existing methods as lambda
expressions making those one-line lambda
expressions even shorter the best part
about these features there
backward-compatible down to Gingerbread
so whether you're building for the
latest version of Android or not you'll
be able to shave off some boilerplate
code this works because the Jack tool
chain is able to implement these new
features using anonymous classes just as
if you had written the old version of
the code yourself that also means you
shouldn't go overboard with using them
in tight loops or anything they're still
relatively expensive however if you are
min SDK version 24 you've entered a
magical land you can take advantage of a
number of additional features for
example lambda expressions go perfectly
with the stream api's which allow you to
chain together multiple operations such
as filtering mapping or converting into
different types before applying a
terminating method such as sum for a
stream events or for each for applying a
lambda expression to every remaining
item oh and it supports running in
parallel out of the box crazy powerful
stuff and I'd encourage you to check out
the docs for all the details as there's
a lot of them
interfaces also got an upgrade with the
ability to add default method
implementations and static methods this
makes it easy to add new methods to an
interface without having to update every
implementation of the interface and
allows you to play static helper methods
related to an interface in the interface
itself and if you're a fan of
annotations and I know some of you are
you'll be able to take advantage of
repeating annotations to add the same
annotation more than once particularly
useful if you have an annotation that
accepts different type elements so lots
of great new features both in the
backward metal and non dock work memo
nature new tools to help you build
better apps
you